(pop music)
- [Narrator] Peace,
love and rock and roll.
It's the hippie creed
along with some flower
power and some crunchy granola.
And we call hippies ‘crunchy granola’
because of, well, granola.
The link between the people,
the culture and the granola,
it started in 1969 at Woodstock.
Organizers estimated that
200,000 fun-loving people
would fill the small
town of Bethel, New York
for the three-day historic festival.
But the number of attending
doubled and the next thing
they knew, there were over
400,000 people camping out,
which led to shortages, food shortages,
and well, that left the munchies-craving,
free-loving hippies a little hangry.
This is where the savior,
Hugh Romney came in.
Hugh and his commune, Hog Farm, were hired
to help organizers run the festival.
Upon seeing the food shortage,
they stepped in to help.
They rounded up a group of volunteers,
hit the streets, and came back with,
you guessed it, granola!
Members of Hog Farm filled tons of cups,
and Hugh took the stage and announced
there would be breakfast
in bed for 400,000.
The hippies ate it up,
and for many, it was
their first introduction
to the crunchy stuff,
and so there you have it,
the original bond between
crunchy granola and hippies
was formed by granola at the one and only
Woodstock Music Festival.
(rock music)